[MUSIC PLAYING]
KOBI MAGNEZI: So GKE's a
managed Kubernetes service.
The fleet is where we
manage the Kubernetes master
and nodes at scale for you.
And it's where we invest
lots of time and thinking
to abstract away the complexity
and variety of options
the framework
offer to you so you
can focus on your workloads,
your business application.
As you can probably know,
the open source community
is super engaged and thrives.
Lots of code changes
and improvement.
And as you can
see on this slide,
I have some data here
from presentation
that was given last
year in a KubeCon.
You can see the amount of
add-ons, repositories, and code
changes that we
need to manage when
we think about managing about
Kubernetes clusters for you
in the fleet.
Our goal with GKE is to
actually streamline and simplify
the management for your
cluster and provide
a hassle free service.
This means non-disruptive
and continuous service
that support your business
through low and high demand
periods or seasons.
I guess there are different
market segments or market
verticals that I could
use for example here,
but this one evidently
shows you the reliability
we deliver by GKE to
retailer customers
specifically during a very
high peak season, Black
Friday and Cyber Monday.
Among these customers,
we have Loblaw,
which I mentioned before,
Canada's largest retailer.
And I'm really excited
to have Justin here.
And he will share with you
more about their experience
later in the session.
So next, let's dive
into the mechanics
of managing a fleet and
what controls you have.
Kate here will walk you
through some live demos
and show you tools and
capabilities you can use today
to manage disruption and risk.
KATE FITZPATRICK:
So basically, my job
as an engineer on
UK infrastructure
is kind of twofold.
First, ensure reliability
for the product,
but also make sure that
it's easy to maintain.
And on the intersection of
those two different dimensions
is actually the upgrade
story, because as you know,
we're on a fleet
of 1,000 clusters.
And one interesting aspect
of running hosted Kubernetes
is that there are versions.
As you know, we move the
master version regularly.
However, the
upgrade of the nodes
is under your customer control.
So how do we deal
with that situation,
because when the gap between
the control plane and the client
grows, you get you might
run into incompatibility.
One solution here is to have
node [? out ?] upgrades.
And we have such a feature.
However, rarely, or not
as often as we would like,
people use it.
And why is that?
Because it's hard
to give control up.
And that is because upgrades
bring workload disruption.
And while we try to manage
that workload disruption,
that is the reality of it.
Upgrades bring disruption.
And even though our fleet is
different in shape and sizes,
it's even harder to upgrade
smaller clusters, smaller node
pools, because you don't
have extra capacity that can
cover the disruption period.
So what actually happens
behind the scenes
when you upgrade a cluster?
Node by node, we drain a node.
We recreate a VM.
We wait for that VM to
start to become running.
And then we wait for the node
to be registered with the master
and become ready.
And then the
workload is resumed.
So this is the period
where your business might
experience some disruption.
How can we make this better?
Well, if you look
at that timeline,
you can see that there are
certain things that we can move
out from the rescheduling part.
And specifically, we
can create an extra VM,
also called surge VM,
before draining the node.
And you can see how disruption
period actually shortens and it
equals now only the
time that it requires
Kubernetes to reschedule your
workload from node to node.
We call this feature
surge upgrades.
We're going to launch it
in alpha this quarter.
You're welcome to use it.
But what exactly it means
for your workload, well,
I cannot look inside of your
application but what I can do
is that I can create a simple
demo app that is a little bit
more sophisticated
than a stateless thing.
There is a state here.
There is a storage that
I read and write into.
On each of the
graphs, the upper line
is the queries per
second or request
per second for reads and writes.
And the lower line
is the error rate.
So the upper half of
the graph is actually
what happens to the workload
when we do the regular upgrades
as we do them right now.
Kill a node.
Let it come up.
You can see that there
are dips in the traffic
as well as spikes in the errors.
The lower half of
the screen shows
you the same app running on a
similar cluster of three nodes
but during the surge upgrades.
You can see that deep
[? search ?] more shallow
and also the errors
are not that frequent.
But even that proves that
there is only so much magic
that we can do for you
in order to make sure
that your application
is reliable.
It's not a silver
bullet solution.
There is still some things
that you can do as a customer.
And this is where I would
like to take my Google
hat off and just talk about
what workload disruptions are
and what you can do to
protect yourselves against it.
So let's take a look
at my simple app.
I'm running three nodes, which
is the default size on GKE
as you know.
It's not too much.
It's not too little.
It's exactly what you need to
run some sufficient workload.
As you can guess from the
names of those two pods,
I'm running Redis.
It's an implementation detail.
I'm not telling you that
you should run Redis.
It's just to show you
that there is some state.
And to make things a little
bit more interesting,
I actually have a persistent
volume connected to that Redis.
So what happens here?
The client attempts to
perform writes and reads.
And let's take a
look at the code
so that I'm not just
telling you something.
All you need to know is that
I initiate the client that
have the connection to Redis.
And then I attempt a write.
And if it succeeds, I report it.
If it doesn't, I also report it.
And then I read.
And that's it.
That's all I have in
my simple demo app.
So let's take a
look at the logs.
So there are some reads
and writes happening.
When we upgrade a
node, we take it down.
And that means that we
actually kill your pod.
Right.
And that means that
at a certain point
your application starts
[? turning ?] errors.
Of course, Kubernetes
rescheduled
the port and the
situation recovers.
However, there is a period
during which you serve errors.
If we delete the client
itself, as you can guess,
it's going to be even worse.
You will stop serving
traffic altogether.
So you have no connection
to the customer altogether.
What can you do to amend that?
Let's not talk about
Redis for a second here.
Let's talk only
about the client.
One of the obvious
things to do here
is just increase the number
of replicas that you have.
And let's just make
sure that we know what
is happening behind the scenes.
So we had one.
Let's say three.
Three is a good number.
So we see that now immediately
we have three apps, three pods,
scheduled and running.
But what is actually--
where are they running?
Well, turns out that
they all got scheduled
on three different nodes--
on two nodes.
Two of the nodes where the
three replicas got scheduled
are the same, which
means that when
we attempt to upgrade
that particular node,
you will still lose 2/3
of your serving capacity.
So that's still not good enough.
What can we do
[? to amend ?] that?
What we can do is that we
can tell the scheduler, hey,
by the way, I know
what I'm doing,
and try to schedule
those particular replicas
on different nodes,
which is to say
we plan to use podAntiAffinity.
Let's add that.
And we can see that
immediately the scheduler
obeyed our request and
rescheduled the pod so that we
have them evenly
distributed across the nodes
so that we can rely on at least
2/3 of the client's capacity
always be available
during an upgrade.
So if you don't remember
anything from this talk today,
just take this back with you.
Redundancy.
Redundancy is important.
There are many things that
we can do for you at Google,
but you have to take
care of yourself
by providing yourself
a little bit of slack.
What specifically it means.
If you have no idea what
you're doing, that's OK.
Just remember the
simplest formula possible
that [? SRE ?] love, N plus one.
Just give yourself
some breathing room,
but not only give
it but also use it.
You can think about
your application
as different full domains
that you want to separate then
run separately off each
other so that, if part
of your application fails,
the other one still can
survive and serve some traffic.
However, is that good enough
if we have redundancy?
Let's take a look.
So I have prepared
a different cluster,
which is a little bit more.
And what I have here is
I have many more nodes.
I have nine nodes in total.
I also have three replicas of
a client as we saw earlier.
I added them.
But here I also
have six replicas
of Redis, which are
configured to be a cluster.
If you don't know what a Redis
cluster is, it doesn't matter.
What you have to think about it
is there is enough redundancy.
There are three
masters, three slaves,
and they are connected in
such a way that if you lose--
there's a certain threshold.
If you lose certain capacity,
you're still good to go.
But is that good enough?
Let's see.
So let's say I was
working on a script.
And I just forgot
what I was doing
so I just want to run it
to see what was happening.
Turns out I was working on
a script to drain a cluster.
However I left it midway.
And as you can see, I actually
caused a total outage.
I cordoned all the
nodes and I also
removed all the pods, evicted
all the pods from those nodes.
Let me quickly restore
that so that we
can continue with the demo.
Which means that redundancy
that we had didn't save us.
In a matter of seconds,
I created a total outage.
And that can be a human
error or an honest mistake.
What can you do to protect
yourself against that?
And again, Kubernetes
is such a huge universe
that there are many,
many mechanisms.
But the simplest
thing you can do
is you can add the
pod disruption budget.
And pod disruption
budget is a place
where you say, OK, these are
the pods that I want to protect.
And this is the rule
that I want to apply
to the particular
deployment or stateful set
or whatever you have.
For instance, max
unavailable can be only one.
At a time, there should be
only one pod unavailable,
or similarly, just a show of
what pod disruption budget has,
you can also specify
min available.
How many at a time should
be available in [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's apply those two.
So we now have
those two in place.
And we have actually
our application
restored and running.
And you can see that
PTB says that there
is allowed disruption
of pod number one
for each of those
deployments that I have.
So what happens if I will try
to just drain everything again?
Well, this is [? over here. ?]
It looks like good news.
I have messages coming back
that cannot evict the pod.
And that's because
the scheduler knows
that I have certain
rules in place
as to how many replicas
should be running at a time.
And you can see
that, yes, I managed
to get rid of one pod in each
stateful set and deployment,
and I also managed to
[? cordon ?] the nodes,
but there is no total outage.
We're still serving traffic.
We're still OK for the time
when we try to recover.
So redundancy is not enough.
You have to put in
place some protection
if you are extra paranoid.
And that's right to
be extra paranoid.
There will be no demo,
but, additionally, you
can also help us to help you
by providing a little bit
more detail of
what exactly you're
running in your black box.
And specifically you can
use the readiness probe
and the liveness
probe, two things that
are used during the
Kubernetes lifecycle that
help us understand is your
application ready to receive
traffic.
And that's readiness probe.
Or is your application
healthy enough?
And that's liveness probe.
If not, let's restart.
In case of a Redis
that I was using,
those particular things
would be just pinging
the [? live ?] Redis
CLI to make sure
that the instance is available.
So with those three
in place, let's take
a look what happened to
the demo app that I had.
This is just to remind you
how the graphs look before.
And this is after
the app was tuned.
So even with the
current upgrade mode
that we have when we have
to kill a VM at a time,
you're still already
doing much better.
With surge upgrades,
you're almost golden.
But there will be no
magic in this world,
so you will have disruption
at any point of upgrades.
You just have to accept it as
price for staying up to date.
And just a couple
of words of things
that you should not be doing.
One of them is specify
min/maxUnavailable zero
or mean available equals
to the number of replicas
that you're running, because
for us it's just a hard stop.
We cannot do anything, because
the scheduler will refuse
to drain a node where we have
one of your ports running.
Similarly, you should be careful
about the liveness probe,
because if the liveness probe
that you define does not
sustain a load,
and it will fail,
that means that Kubernetes will
think that the application is
unhealthy and
reschedule it, which
means just cascading
failure if you already
are experiencing a severe load.
In the same manner, a
termination grace period
should be something meaningful.
It cannot be zero, which means
that we don't wait whatsoever,
or it cannot be hours when
we have to just wait hours.
And with that, I would like
to hand over to Justin.
JUSTIN WATTS: I'm from Loblaw.
And we are Canada's
largest retailer.
And it's interesting
to think about that.
Canada's like the
second largest--
North America's second
largest landmass.
There's only 33 million
people that live there.
And so it's crazy
to think that it's
like 85% of Canadians shop
in one of our locations
every week.
Right.
And so that's a
whole lot of trust
that our country places in us.
And it's a really deep
customer relationship.
And so as a result, our
mission is pretty big.
We want to help
Canadians live life well.
And so for me at
Loblaw Digital, my goal
is to do that in the
lens of cloud native.
And so I'm really
humbled to work and run
a team called
engineering productivity.
And for us, our mission is
to reduce toil, increase
happiness, and get shit done.
Right.
And it's the
confluence of trying
to have the philosophies of
DevOps and of SRE and of shift
left, and thinking about how
we enable engineers to solve
problems rather
than hiring people
to verify if engineers
solve those problems.
Right.
It's all about enablement.
And what we really love is
that in Kubernetes we're
able to bring that
conversation together.
And the great
demos that you just
saw that manifest YAML,
whether it's actually
how we deploy the application,
scale the application,
adding liveliness
and readiness checks,
you would have SREs
[? entering ?] that.
You would have DevOps
engineers editing that.
Heck, you should
have QAs or anyone
in your organization
actually looking
at understanding what that is.
That's your source of truth.
Right.
Everything is code.
And so overall, the
fundamental goal we have
is to operate at the
intersection of innovation
and stability.
And what's funny is I was
thinking about this today.
Loblaw's actually a
100-year-old company.
And I think about what
we're doing in Kubernetes
and thinking about managing
load and resiliency.
And there's this really
interesting tidbit
I know from our Wikipedia page.
We actually invented
the shopping aisle
in the late 1800s.
And before then, if
you look at old movies,
there was a dude
behind the counter
and he would grab your
stuff and give it to you.
Right.
Like the max number
of customers you
could serve as one, a
redundancy factor of one.
If he didn't make it to
work, nothing could happen.
And the shopping idea is
it's that innovation of what
if we could actually
serve more customers,
and they could serve themselves
and make their lives better.
And it's interesting
being in retail
where we have the ability to
impact not only technology
but what's happening in the
real world with our customers.
Right.
And it's not always
in the data center
that those wins are happening.
It's sometimes actually
in the physical world.
And so it's just been
really interesting to see
how that same message
carries on through 100 years.
So specifically,
what I'd really like
to talk to you
about today-- it's
a very thin sliver
of what we do,
but it's about how GKE has
really made our lives easier.
In 2018, one thing that was
really great for us was it
was the first year that we
had a Black Friday and Cyber
Monday where none of
our systems crashed.
And even more impressive
for us was that we actually
maintained our SLA for response
time and error rate throughout.
And that's just really thanks
to Google and that mission.
It's the first year
we've been running
entirely natively in GCP.
And we're really proud
of that accomplishment.
And so it's great to
focus on error rate.
It's great to focus on
response rate and just be up.
But for me and my
team, like I said,
it's engineering productivity.
It's about getting
things done faster.
It's about reducing toil.
It's about increasing happiness.
And something that's
really, really [? toilful ?]
is upgrades.
Right.
Coming from Canada's
largest retailer
running I believe the largest
data center in the country--
we have two of them,
a PR and a DR--
upgrades are a nightmare.
Right.
They take an entire team of
people, a very concerted effort
to think about how are we
keeping our packages up
to date, our operating
systems up to date,
and our servers up to date.
And so when we saw
the ability to use
the functionality
of auto upgrades,
we were there,
because we didn't want
that to have to be a burden
that our team took on.
And so auto upgrades have
three main benefits--
security, reliability,
and functionality.
And a great example,
if you all know
the runC violation
that recently came out,
it was a really serious CV.
By the time we knew about
it, we were already safe.
Right.
And that's thanks
to the great work
that the Google team are
doing to keep the masters--
and actually in that
case, it was container
OS didn't even have the flaw.
And there's another one.
There was a privilege
escalation CV
that happened late last year.
And that was actually having
those auto upgrades on,
before we found out about
it, we were already safe.
And so from a
security perspective,
it seems like a no brainer.
But something that Kate did
a great job of highlighting
is that work disruption can
be a really serious issue.
And so we love automation.
We love magic.
But sometimes later
can be safer than now.
And I'll give you a
good example as to why.
If I'm in retail, when I upgrade
is actually really important.
If we are in the
middle of Black Friday
or if it's even a
Thursday, because Thursday
is when we launch
our promotions,
I probably don't want to
run that risk of having
a disruption happen,
because in the best case,
we get the really nice
graph that Kate showed.
In the worst case, that
graph's a whole lot nastier.
And so today opting into
auto upgrades, I feel great.
Toil's reduced.
But I don't have
quite enough control.
Today Google will allow you to
set a four hour window of when
they should do their upgrades.
But there's a couple
of things that doesn't
account for unfortunately.
One thing it doesn't
account for is the day
of the week to do that upgrade.
And for that that's
important to us.
And the second is the calendar
year like thinking ahead.
We know when our
big milestones are.
And for retail obviously,
once again, Black Friday
and Cyber Monday, those
two are going to come up.
Please don't touch
our infrastructure
around these times,
or if you're working
in a company that has
code freezes for holidays
or vacations where you
don't have staff on hand,
that's really important.
So some of you might not be
opting into auto upgrades
because you don't
have that control.
We've taken the risk.
And for us, reducing the
toil of having to do it
ourselves was worth the
potential risk of it
going wrong and us having to
be there at an [? odd ?] time.
And then the other one is
about how you upgrade them.
Right now it's an all
or nothing approach.
And when we do it--
Google does it
node by node today.
And what we've
noticed is that we're
running a multi-tenant,
multi-cluster,
and a multi-regional
cluster at that.
At Loblaw, one
interesting thing is
we believe that all of our
businesses are good neighbors.
And that allows us to
invest in something
we call soft multi-tenancy.
We don't have to have the
strict isolation because there's
an implicit trust
between, let's say,
Joe Fresh, which is
our retailing clothing
brand and Shoppers Drug
Mart, where we're doing
beauty products and pharmacy.
And we actually
might want to make
that a really strong connection,
because they may have services
that talk to each other like
their shared communal log in,
which is our PCI-D application.
And so for us multi-cluster
has been really important.
But when we do an upgrade,
when we're exposing that auto
upgrade and that's
going node by node,
we're actually impacting
a lot of our businesses.
And so one feature
that we've really loved
is this idea of node pulls.
And node pulls you
can actually have it
so that an upgrade happens
in a specific node pool.
And so we definitely recommend
not just using the default node
pool.
Right.
And whether you're t-shirt
sizing small, medium,
or large for certain
workloads or doing it
per business, that
gives you an ability
to break up your
upgrades and make sure
they're safe in one
place before moving on.
The second thing that we've seen
is the what are we upgrading.
Right.
And for those of
you today-- like
there's just a lot about
Kubernetes versions.
It's moving extremely quickly.
And whether it's patch,
whether it's major,
or whether it's minor, for
us when we're auto upgrading,
we feel good about that we're
getting new security updates,
but we're not quite sure
what else is coming.
And so I feel like I'm
sleeping safer at night,
but I don't know what
to tell my engineers
they now have access to.
And we felt like
we didn't really
have enough control at times to
understand what channel we're
even on, like that
bleeding edge of alpha
versus beta versus stable.
And so we're hoping that
we can see some more
control in those areas.
But at the same time from
a productivity perspective,
we're really thankful that
we can upgrade very quickly.
And so overall, later can
sometimes be safer than now.
I would suggest that everyone
cares about these upgrades
and their own sanity get off
the manual train into auto
by doing so get the
feedback to Google
for how automatic upgrades
can be made better.
And I think overall we
will be in a better place
if we're focused on engineering.
As a retailer, we want
to sell groceries.
I really don't want to be in the
business of managing operating
systems, managing
upgrades, and having
to staff people for that.
And at the end of the day,
the people that we staff
to do that, I don't know if
anyone was born with the idea
that my big dream in life is
to upgrade operating systems.
Like operations engineers, we
have big ideas and big dreams.
And when I look about
the amazing features
that Kate's showing off, that's
what we want our engineers
to be doing.
Right.
And so I think we
should aim higher
in that regard for the
type of work we're doing
and the impact that we're
having in our organizations.
So overall, we're really
excited by these new features
that are coming out.
We're heavily invested in this
from the Loblaw digital side.
And I'll hand it back to Kobi
to see what's coming next.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Thank you, Justin.
So so far we spoke
about challenges.
We saw some amazing demos.
And we heard from Justin
about their experience.
Next I'm excited to
share with you some
of the new capabilities
we are working on
to actually provide you
with even more control
and flexibility.
We'll be focusing
on three areas--
reduce risk, control
disruption, and manage risk.
Let's talk about the first
one, how you can reduce risk.
And Kate mentioned it before.
So we are actually changing the
way we will be upgrading nodes
in clusters managed by GKE.
Right now the way
we upgrade nodes
is at the time of
the upgrade we'll
go one node after the other.
And we'll remove that
node and bring a new one
with the new version.
That's obviously slightly
disruptive for customers.
And we are changing that
process with the surge upgrade.
So with surge upgrade,
we'll actually
create a new node first.
And then we'll gracefully
drain the old one.
And at that time, we'll
remove the old node.
What that gives you
is a few things.
One, it allows us to secure
resources before we even
start upgrades, because we
create that node before we
take the old one down.
The second thing is we
ensure successful completion
of the node upgrade.
We protect your capacity.
Right.
So at any given
point of time you
have the number of
nodes you expect
to have even during upgrades.
And that in turn reduce
disruption and reduce downtime.
Justin mentioned the Maintenance
Windows support we have today.
So yes, you can create
Maintenance Windows.
And we will respect that.
Basically, the feature
that we have right now
supports four hours Maintenance
Windows in any given day.
So obviously there is less
flexibility right now.
Next we are actually going
to enhance the maintenance
windows' capabilities to
support different use cases,
like the use case
that Justin mentioned.
So let's say you prefer to
avoid upgrades during weekends,
because you are a gaming
company and most of the traffic
is coming in through
the weekends.
You'll be able to do that
with the enhanced maintenance
windows support.
If you are a
retailer and you are
trying to avoid completely any
maintenance events during Black
Friday, Cyber
Monday, you will be
able to specify
the range of dates
and we will respect
that and avoid upgrades
during those times.
And then lastly, you know
about upcoming upgrade
but you just need more time.
You need more time
to prepare or you
have some internal challenges
that you're facing.
You'll be able to
postpone or snooze
an upgrade for a
short period of time.
That gives you more flexibility
in controlling disruption.
The other way to
control disruption
is really our release notes.
And transparency is
really key for us.
In the release notes, you get
much more information than just
a change log.
You'll get information about
the upcoming release schedule,
the releases that
we are deprecating,
the releases that we are
going to make available.
And the other thing is we
have a four days roll out
policy in GKE.
So we roll out new version
in different regions
during four days.
You can actually see that
schedule in the release notes.
So we are publishing
what version
is coming first in which
region and you can actually
plan your upgrade accordingly.
Let's talk about managing risks.
We spoke about ways
to manage risk.
And I think PDP or
pod disruption budget
is super important capability
that we support today,
especially if you have
a stateful application.
But in order to support
your risk mitigation,
canary cluster will allow
you to create a cluster
and designate it for canary
or staging environment.
That in turn will indicate
to us that we should roll out
new versions to
those canary cluster
before we roll them out to
your production clusters.
So there will be a mapping
between your canary clusters
and your production clusters.
So we'll roll out new version.
We'll give you enough time
to run your automate this
to get some confidence.
And when you green
light, the diversion
we'll continue rolling out the
upgrades to production as well.
And another exciting feature
in Q2 is release channels.
We spoke about the amount
of versions we support.
And it's really overwhelming.
And we are trying to make
it easier for customer
and move away from that
structure of supporting
many, many versions to
supporting three channels.
We are thinking right now about
rapid, regular, and stable.
So if you want to get
early access to the latest
and greatest bleeding edge
version of Kubernetes,
you probably want to be
on the rapid channel.
And let's say you have
a testing environment.
You will be able to say, hey,
this is my testing clusters
and I want to subscribe this
cluster to the rapid channel.
We'll make sure to roll
new bleeding edge versions
in that specific cluster.
Same thing with
regular and stable.
Regular will give you
the default version
like the one we have today
available in the fleet.
And stable you will
probably get less features,
but it will be more stable
in terms of the version
accumulate more soak time and
we have more test coverage
for that specific channel.
Just a quick example
of how this may look
like from a command
line perspective.
So you can create a new
cluster and subscribe it
to the rapid channel.
So we spoke about different
and many great features.
And I just want to take a
moment to kind of bring it
all together.
Our goal is to keep your
cluster up and running
and deliver non-disruptive
experience even
during upgrades.
And visibility is key for
us as I mentioned before.
We want to make sure that
you understand our product
lifecycle and you
can plan accordingly.
We aim to provide hassle
free managed Kubernetes
service so you can focus
on what you care about
and your core business.
If you are interested in
any one of the features
that I mentioned today, please
follow this link and you
can sign up and share
with us your interest
in joining the alpha program
for one of these features.
[MUSIC PLAYING]